hello everyone this is samir from audio
science review
today i have a review for you of this
little dongle
you all know that uh headphone jacks are
going away or have been going away for
quite a while on
phones and so people are always looking
for a way to
get quality uh sound on their headphones
uh
undergo and the little cheapy dongles
that you get
uh for free or for nine bucks uh
they do the job but they're certainly
not going to drive any uh
high quality headphones uh uh on that
maybe some
you know sensitive iems would be fine
and so i've been reviewing a ton of
these dongles of all different shapes
and forms and
this one is uh from a company called
hides or heidi's i don't know how they
pronounce it
h-i-d-i-s
and it's the model s9 i tested the model
s8 of this and it was groundbreaking
uh in that it provided basically desktop
class
uh dac performance uh in this little
package
uh which was remarkable at the time so
this
new one i'm assuming is the replacement
for it it's the s9
and one difference with this one and
that is that it has
both balance and unbalanced output uh
typically
uh on a balanced output quadruples the
power
versus unbalance and power is the main
problem with these things they're
always power limited uh for high
impedance headphones especially so
typical sennheiser hd 6x or 650 there
are 300 ohms usually
suffer with a lot of these dongles on
this thing so
let's get into the reviews of this one
and see how it does
um this is the price on amazon it comes
in different colors obviously it's
black one that's the silver one uh it's
120 dollars so compared to a nine dollar
dongle is
a lot more money uh the older version
had up down volume control which they
removed which is sad
uh but uh you know you can use the
volume control on your phone
um uh it's based on this akm uh
ak 4493 eq um
dac chip uh you know it has all the
speeds and feeds
not really material for most of what we
do
so let's get into the review and and see
how it does
by the way it runs a little warm which
tells me that it uses fair bit of power
i didn't try to measure it but
it may not last long on a phone that's
not plugged in
uh on this thing um we always start with
our dashboard but since we have two
outputs balanced and unbalanced
we have got to test them both
independently so this is with 3.5
millimeter
output which puts out the same 2.1 volts
that the
previous generation did and it's the
same voltage that desktop tax
produced which is quite good but when
you go to unbalance the voltage jumps up
to 4 volts
which is excellent 4.2 volts almost and
uh
look at the distortion here the highest
peak is third harmonic at minus 125 db
remember i said we are what we're
looking for is first as far as threshold
here is -115
and this thing's 10 db better than
threshold of hearing and
you're getting in this tiny little
package and
uh noise though adds to that and
drags sign that down to 112 and when i
said drag
it's still incredibly good look at where
it lands
this area is really top of the class the
ones in blue
and this thing is in the middle there's
probably i'd say 200 decks that are
worse than it
some of them probably ten or twelve
thousand dollar decks that can't do as
well as this little
uh tiny dongle can do um
signal noise ratio is great uh not state
of the art by desktop standards but by
dongles it's great you're getting
19 and a half bits of dynamic range
at full volume when you crank it down to
50 millivolts which is what we use to
test for hissed noise it drops down to
80 db
for a desktop deck that wouldn't be very
good it basically says if you play as
louder than 80 db you're going to hear
potentially some background hiss
in there with sensitive iem so uh it
does the job but if you have super
sensitive iem this may not be as good
it also possible that this noise is
dependent on what you plug it into
these little devices don't have a lot of
filtering in them so
you know my desktop windows machine that
i use to test with
generates a lot of noise over usb so
it's possible that might be a little
cleaner on
on some other device that you plug it
into
uh jitter noise in these little dongles
again for the same reason
their jitter performance or gender tests
that we run
always shows a lot of you know spikes
and noise from the
host that bleeds into them again there's
not enough room in there to put
lots of regulation and filtering in
there but still look at the
levels of them the worst case is
something at two kilohertz is minus 120
db
so well below threshold of hearing and
all these other ones are clearly well
below the threshold of hearing so very
very controlled
even though it looks dirty to the eye
part of the reason looks bad is because
the noise floor is so low
a lot of these dongles hover up here uh
if you look at the typical google
dongles and what have you the noise
floors up here which
tends to hide a lot of this because this
thing is so clean
on its own it shows some of the usb
activity
that's bleeding up here a lot of people
complain that why do you test with just
one tone so all right we'll test with 32
tones and so these are 32 tones and
these tones if the device is not 100
linear
meaning transparent then they generate
intermodulation distortions and they all
pile up in what we call grass down here
uh we see that at low frequencies there
is no grass to speak of
uh we're at 120 db which is 20 bits of
distortion free range and here it even
goes down as we go up in frequencies
and we get up to 21 bits this is
beyond good uh i mean this is desktop
class best measure performance ever i
have is 22 bits
for state-of-the-art dac and here we
have a little dongle
costing 100 bucks that's getting up to
21 bits so
distortion is just not in the equation
this thing is going to
sound clean clean clean
there's a weird thing in that my audio
analyzer only talks through this
interface called asio and the azio
interface that i have for certain class
of devices like these dongles
the emulator layer that i have always
screws up and adds its own noise in
there
i don't know why and it's an open source
uh it's a freebie type of
plugin that does that and there's no
support for why it doesn't so
uh please excuse the fact that this is
elevated noise it's actual noise is not
up here it's probably somewhere down
here
um so but still let's look at how much
power we get
at max level we get 52 milliwatts
i'll show you in a second what a typical
dongle produces this is
a lot of power uh with a 300 ohm load
and it's not because we have four volts
of output and that's what helps there
searching to 33 ohm load where we stress
current delivery now
we get 0.1 watt which is a lot of power
again in the low dongle
how much power look at that 300 ohm
where it finishes
these other two devices are huge they're
more
powerful than their massive little
bricks
nothing this small has this kind of
power uh if you go over here
um [ __ ] dragonfly black which is you
know audioquest
dongle that a lot of people buy look at
where that is waiting down here
it doesn't even put out one mil water
power in there um
apple dongle 3.6 milliwatts and that's
one of the better ones and instead of
3.6
you have 52 milliwatts in here so you
have 15 times more power
than an apple dongle uh the s8 that was
uh before it didn't have as much power
because it was unbalanced
and so put out half the voltage and you
get quarter of the power
on this thing switching to 33 ohm load
um
we see that again it performs superbly
and
it produces 110 milliwatts
again going down here let's see if we
can find
the apple dongle there's a samsung phone
that i have my own uh samsung s8 plus
puts out 28 milliwatts this thing puts
out 110 millibars so four times more
than my phone by itself
which is quite significant again if you
have inefficient headphones
uh on this thing uh the google dongles
53 milliwatts
so we have more than twice as much power
so
amazing amazing amount of power in in
this little package
um i always listen to these devices to
headphone amplifiers because they can
run out of power and
you hear that so easily you don't need
double blind tests or anything you crank
up the volume if it starts to get
distorted and crackle
and um or mute you know you know that
they can't
drive that headphone so i start with a
sennheiser hd 650
this is a 300 ohm headphone
so it requires a lot of voltage to get
power out of it
and this little guy even though i was
using unbalanced mode which is the lower
power
setting in it it still had no trouble
driving that
just delightful performance i mean it
just sounded beautiful
detail everything no it won't blow the
drivers out like a desktop amplifier can
do
with desktop amps i can turn it up
enough where literally my earlobes will
start to
vibrate i'm going to do that for one
second don't don't copy me
you can't get to that level performance
but you know you don't listen at that
level you listen to everyday
level and it was more than enough and
this is unbalanced you can get a
balanced cable for hd650 and then
you get quadruple the power then the
killer headphone i have is this uh
ether uh cx from drop or dank lock audio
and um usually this is a pain in the
neck the drive because it's only 25 ohm
impedance so it requires tons of current
to drive
there are desktop decks that have
trouble with driving this headphone
not this little dongle i tell you it
drove it beautifully there was plenty of
volume the dynamics the fidelity
i mean it was just great i just sat
there enjoying
the sound out of coming out of this
little dongle and uh
it would be nothing to apologize for i
mean it was that good
uh on this thing so
you know i i just i was so excited over
the s8 and then
you know with this one it's just i'm
over the boom with it if you have a
standard laptop
that you listen to the internal dacs and
those things may be okay but they just
have no volume
a lot of them also have high impedance
and they also pick up noise from the pc
sometimes
just get this thing plug it in takes no
space this little thing
you know hanging in there you should
give you far better performance than
you get on the baseboard motherboard
even on a desktop if it comes for the
headphone output they're usually
pretty janky uh get this it just would
be fantastic
on uh with your phone and a tablet it's
just a
it's a live server you basically can
have your desktop life
on the go or even sitting at your
desktop
with this little thing and doesn't need
an external brick
or ac power or anything you just plug it
in in line
on if you're running on battery though i
suspect it'll suck the juices out dry
so i don't know how useful it is in that
scenario i'll have to measure it or you
need to ask on the forum people have it
so
you know what the battery life is you
can always turn it down and not use as
much power
on this thing so a wonderful little find
is you know state-of-the-art dac
performance in a tiny little package
with somebody who understood engineering
and did a great job designing this so
can't recommend it enough uh yeah 120
dollars a lot of money but hey
stop buying those expensive
coffee and you're not going out anyway
with the
pandemic going on so see the money that
you save
put it towards good good audio product
that uh give you a lot of enjoyment
okay that's it see you in a future video
bye bye